皆様大変お待たせいたしました
第2回エンディング発表かー
そういうわけで第2回となるリンクなんですけども第1回目の優勝されたエンディング
がただいまの肇社長の動画に使われている縁でございます
悲しく6
これが最後の今日の動画があのエンディングを使う最後になりますのでぜひ
最後までご覧くださいません何年ぐらい使ったんだろーっ
相当昔から使ってるんですよね ed て言ったらゴッキー以前が出て来2016年8
月にとってるって公募約4年ぶりですね4年ぶりに外れ社長の動画のエンディングを
変えることになりました
だから当初4年前をエンディング変えたときになんか前の方が良かったみたいなと言っ
たんですけどもそんな
あっという間にせずな自分で今回の発表会でエンディングが変わっても大丈夫ですなり
ます世の中誰ですお湯でサッソゲエンディング発表会見て行きたいと思います今回の
応募数なんと
1,133件のご応募でしたたくさん年リングありがとうございますスクールのすごい
大変だったと思うんですけど本当にたくさんの方のご応募がありましたありがとう
ございます
ですが世の中は厳しいものでチェーン刺されて良いセグ3のエンディングをあの準備
僕がズームしたわけではないんですけどもよりセルフィーのエンディングを中止してい
たしましたので採用され9人が1つなんですけども本当にたくさんの素敵な
エンディングがあったまで面白いとかこれはちょっとグッドデザイン賞見て熱があっ
たら紹介していきたいとおもいます
では行こうやっぱりだけで刺す原理組
いきましょうまず最長作品どうぞ
って俺が押すんだけどねこちらです
を
もうすぐめっちゃキレ別きれい
おおおおすごい
なんかめっちゃ下の人めっちゃ古いとだけどねぇ
菅畑のイメージなんでしょうねみんなで金を取ってる感じ
すごい
始めすることは動画投稿した
投稿するすごく選んでもこのアニメーションみたいなろー
蟷螂したが増えた
的なぜコメント行為
みんなやられとるやんけ
初めは神動画を投稿した
敵を倒した登録者の負託を受けた後ネームドの盾を手に入れた
あれだ様の負担でも様子が
[音楽]
ストーリーやに名称そうだけどストーリー性もこうアンチコメント書かれたりだけ立て
てに比べからしたければ議員でした本当ありがとうございますどんどん行きましょう
いやーすごいですねーええっ
始めん
見れるなんてさんと言うんだ誰だよどうぞ
採用大木さんの作品ですどうぞ
[音楽]
牛最後俺じゃないしプーンっ
かわいい
[音楽]
女凄い
なんかほっこりしますねー
すごい声だったらあこれでおすすめ動画のセールなう
はすごいかわいいめっちゃ可愛いじゃないですかこれ
ちん子えっなんでなんじゃなく沈降えい
林くん載せてある
[音楽]
ああ
フィン
ああなるほどなのだロード僕期以来じゃないっすよ
はい
voodoo
ブーン
澤が粋なん
ね月すごいワインディングきた時の衝撃すごいんでしょうねこれ素晴らしい
てもいいしますと素敵でしたねと思いますどんな良い場所
フィッ
[拍手]
大優劣と昨日ねなるほどなろうなろうぞ
よくわかんないぞーが謎とは次ですこちらです
これかっ
3分で作りましたまだ雑すぎずおお
まあすごいいい感じ
道央
メッツリズムに乗ってていい感じですねなんか見やすかったですいいね水でさでござい
ます次です
フ
ピン
[音楽]
おおおおあぁすごいすごいすごいラストなぁ
[拍手]
[音楽]
ピース音シンプルでおおーー
つつじ素敵これも正攻法ですねつぎです
[音楽]
うーん
俺の朝の横揺れは一体おっ
可愛いかわいい素敵ですありがとうございますいいともいいと思う俺の謎の横揺れが
あったんですけどね
次です
[音楽]
阿蘇現実な実弾の中で正規 the 削ぎキスなぁ
おっ
かわいい
[音楽]
まあすごい
すごいレッツ綺麗にまとまっているいい感じですねやっぱりクオリティ高いな今回も
大
すぐ
水シンプルシンプルめっちゃ綺麗だったんですけどちょっとで100岩盤
早かった気がしますねちょっと見たりとかすると大変なのかも知れませんけどめっちゃ
よかったですごいこれで実はございません
大
すごいすごい
もうすごい
すごいて楽器ああああ消えちゃったん
今日も1日お疲れ俺に向かって売れてるのかな
次です
ココア
[音楽]
早独特僕と栩タイミングが数度とちゃんと起きなさいそれさんと受けても養い4の
をレーダーで合わせ5位オレっぽい
[音楽]
大
すごいいろんなあるの服装になってますねん
[音楽]
うわぁ凄い
動いてる
あっはぁっ
俺んと出てるん
[拍手]
あーおれが歌ってたなマネー
いや遅いそのままはそれじゃん
一周いる今の
を
大
[音楽]
俺だぁああ
すごい
[音楽]
うわぁ
バス上でも
お手手手手手手手手編を
はいないはずん
おすごいてを
大
すごい
女伊勢元のデイリーライフすごい
うわぁ
[音楽]
かっこいい
すごいああ
番外はじめの絶対インスタグラム
もうすごい
音が凄くかっこいいですねー
はいん
[音楽]
rock crew
b が入っております
[音楽]
まじかん
4を
ああああああ
すげーさは以下
もうすごい
[音楽]
さわやかーれめっちゃ年か俺は好きでしたねりねっち系の綺麗な番組のは甲板に出てき
そうな感じ
good です
俺はすごいすごいえっ
[音楽]
かわいい4すごい次デー
オールなぁすごいかわいい
口が w になっていく
第二は2ちょんでしてほしいです本当にわかってる猫なって youtube なこと
を
いやいやんん
ねぇまぁ俺じゃないよおいいいとだ俺じゃない人は何か言いますけど
うん
なにこれ
[音楽]
おしゃれ
すごいすごいすごい
[音楽]
あーイラスト川湯びっくりした人にすげー
もうぜっっ
よくできてるなぁ
すげー
はすごいすごいすごいすごい
かわいい
me
uh
car
あっはぁ